pour la journée nationale du commerce de
proximité la ville de maurepas et
l'association des commerçants de la
commune ont investi la place du
sancerrois
les animations étaient proposées toute
la journée pour faire découvrir leur
métier
nous avons une esthéticienne on a un
piano derrière qui permet aux clients de
venir jouer et donc on essaie d'animer
la place pour que les gens profitent de
cette journée bien ensoleillée et que
les ligues les comment les commerçants
présentent leur métier
exposition sur la laine à tricoter qu
dégustation à la boulangerie en plus des
stands installés les commerçants réservé
un accueil spécial aux clients au sein
même de leurs boutiques pour qu'ils nous
lâchent qu'ils continuent à venir chez
nous à nous faire travailler
c'est important pour la ville pour faire
vivre le centre ville nous faire vivre
c'est la cinquième année que maurepas
participent à cette journée nationale
sur les trente membres de l'association
des commerçants 20 se sont mobilisés ce
qui vaut à la ville une récompense de 2
sourire du comité national du commerce
de proximité
les sourires récompense la synergie
entre la ville et l'union des
commerçants
un dossier est envoyé auprès d'eux
l'association gncp qui est la journée
nationale du commerce de proximité
ils viennent aussi vérifier sur place ce
qui se passe comme animation ils vont
visiter les commerces qui participent et
en fonction en fonction de ce qu'ils ont
vu ils vont décerner jusqu'à 4 sourire
la ville et ses commerçants souhaitent
déjà participé à leur sixième édition et
pourquoi pas obtenir un troisième
sourire